Rime initially felt to me like a
mishmash of journey the Last Guardian
the witness and brothers a tale of two
suns which is handy because I like all
those games thankfully from what I
gathered in our recent hour-long creevy
though rhyme doesn't have the
aggravating controls of the Last
Guardian probably because your furry
companion is capsized and not elephant
sized and it doesn't feature the
occasional frustrating difficulty spikes
of the witness perhaps even more
importantly so far it doesn't feel like
it's borrowing too heavily from any of
these games to check out our latest
gameplay clips and trailers for I'm do
hit that subscribe button but for now
let me give you a better idea of the
game during our preview all I could
think was how much my recent gaming
habits could do with a palette refresh
alike rhyme after spending 60 hours with
horizon zero dawn and another hundred
plus hours with persona 5 I'm so ready
for a game that isn't afraid to be quiet
to just let you move slowly at your own
pace take your time with puzzles or
listen to waves crashing up against
ancient buildings that isn't to say
there's nothing tense about rhyme if you
caught our recent gameplay clip you'll
see a section where the boys evading the
claws of a giant bird but there is still
plenty of time for scenery admiring
pillar climbing and Fox / friending
there's no dialogue in rhyme so much
like in journey or brothers a tale of
two sons you'll need to pay attention to
try and interpret what's happening on
your own rime uses painted murals placed
throughout the world to hint at who the
protagonist is where he came from and
what's going on in the world you may
have noticed from the gameplay you've
been watching over the last minute or
two that there really aren't a lot of
characters in the game apart from the
protagonist which evokes a mysterious
and lonely vibe it's a feeling that is
exacerbated by the fact that every so
often a mysterious figure pops up and
subsequently disappears every time you
get close to them rime is essentially
linear with some large explorable
sections that open up through puzzle
solving but I don't mind that I think
linear games get a bad rap but I
appreciate how you're able to get a very
specific vision communicated from
developer to player as a result of being
funneled down a particular
the paths rhyme producer Cody Bradley
told us the team put a lot of work into
tweaking the difficulty curve to ensure
players would feel challenged but not
overwhelmed while it aired on the side
of ease since we were early in the game
that generally seems to ring true at
least in our short preview session
sequencers tended to follow the same
pattern the player is introduced to a
new mechanic with a basic puzzle and the
following uses of that mechanic
gradually ramp up in difficulty beyond
the puzzling though the world is really
inviting the ico ask art style fits
really nicely with the feel of the game
which is a little bit mysterious and a
little bit magical what really brought
it a step up for me with the little
details when jumping upon a suspended
metal platform the structure clangs and
bends under your weight you get a trophy
for not crushing any bird eggs on your
way up an ancient building and you can
choose to either bait a wild pig with a
tasty treat or scare it to the area you
need it to be much like The Last
Guardian it also puts care into giving
you the feeling that you aren't
embodying just any protagonist but a
child from the way the boy runs from
place to place to his infectious join
climbing high objects or solving puzzles
by chucking a ball across a room the age
of your protagonist really shines
through as you progress if the Fox is
around the boy will say hello to it and
if he's on his own he'll hum to himself
it's too early to make a call in the
entire game but personally I think if
developers care enough to get the little
things right it's a sign that the
overall game direction has been treated
with care too
[Music]